foreign
naturally a very angry person what are
you carrying that you don't want to
carry anymore something was done to me
at a very young age that was not okay
and he's sexually abused yes but it's
like what good comes out from anybody
knowing what happened freedom
yo yo what's up this is John with the Dr
John deloney show
so glad you joined us and you're hanging
out with us and I hope that life's
treating you well and if it's not you've
come to the right place and if it is
treating you well you come to the right
place greatest podcast about mental
health and parenting and marriage and
schools ever ever ever and
um we had to do this intro twice because
I was like
whoa coming in and my voice cracked
because hashtag just going through
puberty just saying
um my doctor told me eventually what
happened and ladies and gentlemen today
today I'm so excited for you so proud of
you thank you it's a big day it's a big
day actually Ben Hill is back there on
the booth we've started an incredible
metal band together and we're gearing up
for our Big Show
so there's lots of uh
let's be
honest it's incredible we're gonna win I
mean there's not even I don't even know
why other bands are entering actually it
should just be a 45 minute set from us
Actually I don't even think we're that
good but for 10 minutes oh we can we can
do 45.
yeah but that leads me to puberty so
we're back everybody and on that note
we're gonna go and talk to Jill in Grand
Rapids what's up Jill
hi Dr John how are you good hey you
heard the first intro not so great huh
hey so good okay look into my future
with my 10 year old
[Laughter]
exactly except he may be in his 40s okay
so what's up how can I help
um well I'll just give it a little bit
of backstory here
um I've been married for about 12 years
and my husband previously worked in
community mental health for over a
decade
and for the last five years he went into
private practice as a trauma-focused
therapist which he's amazing at and I've
never seen him so excited to go to work
and come home and excited to talk about
it
um so I'm really thankful for that
however I have noticed a little bit of a
shift in our relationship how we might
handle situations with the kids a little
bit differently
um and so I was just wondering if you
had any insight as to how to help
support ramuna's job make him feel like
I
I'm not against his job I just would
like my husband to be home when he's
home and not him to come home as a
therapist
you did an incredible
Central to Northern Michigan job
of painting a really messy situation in
as bright a colors as you can
and I know this because I've lived this
exact thing
it's hard isn't it
yeah
tell me more about it
um
it's hard because sometimes I feel like
nope you're saying really nice things
sometimes I feel
tell me what's happening
I'm being talked to in our conversations
like a client there you go
what does that mean
it makes me
it makes me feel
um
like I'm just another person
um
not supported not supportive for who I
am at times
and as though you're a person to be
fixed or a problem to be solved or a
series of
actions away from being the person you
are supposed to be whatever that means
just use listening to your language it's
very distancing language
like you and I could just have a
conversation and I would know you
interact regularly with somebody who
works in mental health and I've been
talking to you for about 90 seconds
um because everything is distance
focused all of your language has has
space in it from
the actual actor and what it's doing to
you
hear what I'm saying
um give me an example where you're not
being supported
um or give me a scenario play something
out for me
well when we're having particularly our
oldest child when we when there is a
situation and
um
we I I do something about it I say
something I
um do something about it
I'm not always getting the backup from
him
um are you getting some sort of clinical
explanation or he comes over the top of
you
um it'll
I don't feel like we're on the same page
as far as working with him on certain
things my my oldest has had a lot of
medical trauma um so he's really good at
putting that hat on to help him out and
kind of almost back him up instead of
backing me up and being a team when
we're working with our kids on something
this is going to sound bananas
but your son needs a dad more than a
trauma therapist and it that lives with
him
uh-huh
does that make sense
yeah and I know that you need a husband
more so than a living expert who's going
to guide Garden direct everything that
happens inside that little home
right what does the conversation look
like when you've talked to him about
this
but many times it comes out in our
argument or heated discussions if you
will
um where I might say something and it
comes back to him as
I'm not good enough you don't like my
job
um
and it's very hard because he's an
internal processor and I'm outward so I
pretty much will say it and I don't
always
mean it to offend him it's just how I'm
working through something well he gets
he gets to choose whether he's offended
or not
yeah that's the choice he's making
um
I applaud you for speaking your needs
out loud now if you're rude or you're a
jerk or you're trying to throw grenades
at him that's another thing that doesn't
sound like that at all sounds like
you're saying things like I don't I'm
tired of being treated like a client
here or you're coming home after dealing
with kids trauma over and over and over
and you're bringing that that
brittleness and that edge and you want
to talk about it all the time and then
that leads into every interaction with
our kids is like a is a clinical
interaction like I need you to come home
and put that stuff down
um
that sounds like what you're doing more
than the other is that right
yeah
occasionally I hit him but other than
that
um no hitting
um
so here's the deal
I won't get into my specifics I don't
want to make your story about me other
than to say I I was him
I brought that home
and I wasn't a technically a trauma
counselor per se but I spent my nights
and weekends in hospitals for people
over and over and over and I spent my
days sitting with people who were
falling apart at the seams and who are
struggling to
reconcile with tough decisions they'd
made Etc
and then I brought it home I wanted to
talk about it and I talked to my wife
like she was dumber than me like I had
all the answers because I'd read some
article by the way psychological
articles are less than 50 percent
reproducible which means they're often
garbage they're trash
they're not anyway
that's an aside
um so here's the deal you have every
right it's let me say it this way it's
unethical for him
to wear his hat as a therapist inside of
his home
it's unethical it's wrong it's against
professional ethics
he should not treat his child like a
therapist he shouldn't treat his wife
like a therapist he shouldn't treat his
son like a client or his wife like a
client or his friends at work or school
um I'm sorry his friends at church or in
the neighbors or at the wait
he should treat his clients like clients
it's like boxers Who come out of the gym
leaving their boxing gloves on and then
just deciding to punch people at home
that's just not you can't do that okay
here's the unfortunate thing and then
here's the the empowering thing the
unfortunate thing is you can't make him
take that hat off
okay that's a choice he has to make when
he decides to be a little more mature in
his professional ethics and when he gets
a little more comfortable in
differentiating his work life from his
home life he needs to figure that out
really quickly okay
you can
um stop responding to it
and this is where you have the right and
the opportunity to say with respect and
dignity and kindness hey um I'm not your
client and if you talk to me like your
client then I'm understanding that
you're choosing to end this conversation
and then he gets to choose and the first
time you do that your heart's going to
beat really fast you're probably gonna
get sweaty like it's going to feel
awkward and weird and he might throw a
fit up against that boundary
what is that supposed to mean I don't
even know what you're talking about and
then you're gonna have to articulate it
very clear
okay very very clear when you talk to me
like this
my wife told me here I said I'm not
going to make it about me but I am my
wife said you have a very particular
tone when you talk to me or the kids
your jaw sets in a certain way you have
a body posture
that doesn't say with it says at or it
feels over and she was very very
specific
and it gave me some things to to work on
right I will not be treated like a
client I'm your wife
I get equal say we get equal insights
and we're going to do this thing this
parenting thing together have you all
ever gone out for lunch and just talked
about what what the end game is with
your oldest
oh yeah so many times where's the
disconnect there
[Music]
is
he sees how I may
want to or choose to parent
um him in a situation
and see the he's seen the effects of
that in his job and so I think there's
some of that is there's the fear so be
be specific do you you get mad at your
kid and you yell and then your husband's
going to work every day dealing with
kids who are traumatized or do you hit
your kid like what's what's the thing
that your husband's responding to
I'm
I guess I'm a little bit more
my kid knows my buttons and so he pushes
them and I react to it okay I don't
always respond to it no I don't hit them
but I I may talk to them like I've told
you how many times
um or no you're not going to ride your
bike because last time you didn't tell
us where you were
and so what about that does a trauma
therapist feel like they need to
intervene on
um
I don't
I don't think he he will he doesn't say
hey look your mom said you can't ride
your bike he's like if he's gonna go
cool off let him go ride his bike
yeah that has absolutely nothing to be
nothing
with being a trauma therapist
like you're destroying your relationship
with him because of A B C or D
or or
you're holding him accountable to
certain boundaries
to keep him safe
right
yeah
um some of it too is his background is
the his parents were hard on him that's
it right there so that I don't know if
that
here's the deal there is a there is a a
movement within the trauma therapy world
and here's why I'm feeling this like my
if you were looking watching me now like
my shoulders are tensed up right now I'm
having to breathe through this one
because I've done this and I see the
destructive nature this has in my home
had in my home okay me treating my wife
and my kids like this
the second thing is is there is a
Insidious thread of support and help
through the trauma counseling movement
which I think is an incredible thing we
are identify I'd speak all over the
country on trauma I get it
um I get it more than most and it's a
huge deal and it affects Millions more
people who than people think they do
and
simply taking people who have been hurt
who've experienced big trauma acute
trauma secondary trauma
and
not wanting to make them any more
uncomfortable
is not the way forward in fact it makes
him least less resilient and it
reinforces that anxious mechanism that
keeps them spun up all the time they
have to be walked through hard things
that's the whole point of trauma
counseling and so I tell you that to
tell you
if there's never tension between a
parent and a child then the parent is
failing miserably in their job
what you have is not a trauma counselor
who's trying to be supportive here's
another thing that I mean I used to say
certain things to my kids to my son
especially when he was younger
when it came to discipline and my wife
who is a pedagogical expert
working with kids and she also had a
background of training with discipline
with young boys
she said hey if you do it like this this
is not helpful what you're trying to get
is this try this way instead and what
she had was a set of skills it wasn't an
undermining because she got
uncomfortable or nervous during an
engagement see the difference
so one is
um
I he feels uncomfortable and so he's
gonna jump in there and make this thing
make himself feel better by making you
feel small
another is hey I actually have some
expertise here and I'm going to talk to
you about it offline
because I I know your heart honey and I
know what you're trying to get this
young boy and I'm gonna I know a better
a quicker better way to get there
that's a totally different proposition
but hear me say this is about him not
the Trump the trauma therapy is simply
he uses that to back to make excuses for
himself
and I'm sorry for that what you have to
do
is say here's what I will accept and
that might be you sitting down saying
um no more well I accept you
undermining me in front of our kids if
you have a problem with some of the
things I'm the way I've said something
the way I've I've reacted to something
then I asked you to respect me enough to
have that conversation offline and I
promise you that I will be willing to
listen if we do it in a respectful way
foreign
yes and sometimes he does say things and
sometimes he's just completely silent
okay and just allows it to get
I would say worse but get louder well
and that's what hey hold on I'm gonna
step in so it's either he chooses to do
that or he chooses not to step in at all
right and I
you're not off the hook either
you've got to stop responding to kids
yeah they don't get that from you
is that fair
and you might need to be humble and
change a few things about how you're
approaching things
yeah is that fair
oh yeah my guess is the bigger component
here the umbrella over all of this is
your husband traffic's in trauma he
deals with trauma for a living
and he comes home disconnected from
himself
and he is unable to be present with his
family the people who love him the most
because literally to do the work he does
every day he has to unhook his soul from
himself
does that make sense
yeah and so what you're really asking
for is a husband to come home and be
present
and when husbands don't know how to come
home and be present they come home and
do work
they do jobs
like fix their wives and instruct their
children
see what I'm saying
yep
here's here's what I would do moving
forward I would I would come up with
your boundaries and be I can't express I
can't express this enough you got to be
super clear
when you say these things you are
choosing to end a conversation with me
because I am choosing to no longer be
talked to like that
if you have ways that you can teach and
coach me because you've got some
expertise in an area I would love to
hear it here's how and when I will hear
that
if I am finding myself reacting
I will ask that you will just walk by
here's what I asked my wife to do I
asked her to walk by and just put her
hand on my arm just gently like this and
she does she did it for a couple of
years and now I don't react anymore
because she was catching me in the
moment I could feel oh there I am
and I was able to take a breath and stop
myself
and you Jill have to be intentional
about stopping being so reactive with
your kids
and not apologizing for having
accountability and boundaries this whole
thing feels like it's a mess it feels
like there's bigger relationship issues
at play than just the kids
and
I
he won't go but I think it's time to go
to marriage counselor because I don't
like the trajectory of those so I'm just
being honest with you
this ends
um
in a mess
hopefully he'll go
and if he won't you can say I'm gonna go
I'm gonna go learn some new tools and
and ways to communicate
foreign
[Music]
professional helpers
your family doesn't usually need your
expertise occasionally in a crisis
and I'm talking to police officers I'm
talking to swat officers I'm talking to
counselors I'm talking to nurses
they don't they rarely need your
expertise
but they need more than anything
is you
so don't hide behind your job and all
your knowledge
to show up
to show up we'll be right back
hey deloney here and I've got a word
from our sponsor from betterhelp I've
been on the giving and receiving end of
therapy for years when I was spinning
out like a decade ago with wild anxiety
I had a moment that light bulb moment
that I knew I had to do something
different I knew I had to change
something probably a lot of some things
right but I found myself without the
tools for taking the next step when
you're facing problems or challenges in
life it's way too easy to get stuck in
that anxious spiral of Doom I've been
there but when you learn how to stop
that cycle and start taking ownership of
your life that's when you're free and
that's what therapy can help you do it
gives you the tools you need to do the
problem solving in your own life and
that's why I love better help better
help is online therapy that offers video
phone and even live chat sessions with
your therapist it's more affordable than
in-person therapy plus you can be
matched with a therapist in under 48
hours if you're ready to get the tools
that you need to deal with the
curveballs life's throwing at you
therapy can help visit betterhelp.com
deloney to get 10 off your first month
that's better
help.com slash deloni
all right we are back let's go to Katie
in Dayton Ohio what's up Katie
Hi how are you outstanding how are you
I'm doing all right thanks for taking my
call of course you got it what's up
well my question is how do I forgive my
husband and somewhat my in-laws for
being really irresponsible with student
debt student loans so I uh got married
about a year and a half ago and during
the student loan pause my husband and I
thought we paid off all of his student
loans we went and applied for a mortgage
recently and found out that he had about
14 000 other loans that he didn't know
about and fourteen thousand other loans
or fourteen thousand dollars in another
loan fourteen thousand dollars of
student loans that we did not know about
okay
um and I know we grew up very separate
like differently I my parents were very
on top of teaching me about finances and
making sure I knew what I was getting
into with college debt and things like
that and his parents were a lot more
hands off
and just to have these ones and not know
about them is kind of beyond what I can
comprehend and so I'm really struggling
with all of them just because it feels
like they were very irresponsible and
now it's holding us back in ways that I
wasn't expecting and I want to forgive
all of them and I guess I'm just looking
for advice on how to do that
I have so many questions that are not
really related to your question so I
won't I won't drag this whole call
underwater because I know I do that
sometimes
um
I will say this I you know I worked in
universities for almost two decades
before I came and joined This Crew and
so
um it's very common for parents to take
out student loans in their children's
name
and then use them for other things so
that may have happened
um it may not even be your
husband that took out a loan he just
forgot about
I'll also say that it's super super
common for people to sign up loans to
quote unquote clean off a balance sheet
without ever looking at the loan amount
so what's happened in your home is
it's frustratingly common very very
common that people just take out loans
to pay their rent and to get out of
school and they don't look at that final
number and so for someone like you who
is raised to watch what you owe very
very closely
um this is it doesn't make any sense
just hear me say on the other side of
the of The Ledger this is way way more
common than than you you're the weirdo
in this one okay yeah
um so let me just ask you this are you
gonna leave them
absolutely not are you done with him
you're just like you know what forget
this dude year and a half in he sucks
I'm on to somebody else are you gonna
leave him
okay
um so here's what I'd recommend you do
all right let me ask you are his parents
bad people
no are they like gonna be terrible uh
like in-laws whenever you have kids and
all that I mean they're gonna be just
the worst
okay
so here's what I would do
um I would go out to like Lowe's or Home
Depot or something okay
and I would buy a cinder block
okay it's gonna be like three bucks or
five bucks or something you may have one
laying around your house somewhere
and I want you to get a piece of masking
tape or duct tape and put it across the
whole cinder block
and I want you to write here terrible
financial decisions by husband and
parents okay
and then I want you to hold that cinder
block for 20 to 30 minutes without
setting it down
okay okay
it's good after about 60 seconds it's
going to become so heavy your hands and
arms will go numb and then after about
four or five minutes it's going to be
unbearable
okay
okay if you make 30 minutes you're
stronger than mine than most okay
I'd prefer you to just carry it around
with you until you just need to set it
down right don't injure yourself
um but continue to set it down and I
want you to take it out in the backyard
and throw it in the backyard all the way
by The Back Fence or if you're in an
apartment I want you to go set it down
somewhere in the woods
and I want you to rip the tape off
and never pick that up again
be done with it here's what you're
choosing every every second you don't
forgive
you're opening your eyes and you're
thinking Hmm
I'm gonna make the next few hours
intentionally miserable that's what I'm
gonna do
I'm gonna make my life worse
just cause
it'll feel good
can I tell you what I really think
yeah I think you're mad at yourself
a that you didn't that when y'all were
paying this stuff off you either didn't
pull a credit report or y'all didn't get
you didn't look at the numbers right in
the right way right
um or you're mad because you have some
dream of a timeline like we're gonna do
this then we're gonna have a baby we're
gonna get a house and I want this car
and now this has disrupted your timeline
because there's fourteen thousand more
dollars to pay off right
um unless it just got wiped away maybe
it just got wiped away with the new
stuff right so all that to say is
I think you're often our anger like
you're talking about it's we're mad at
ourselves man
and I'm gonna miss I'm gonna lob that
onto some of this you volunteer you
chose this marriage Katie just be
married right yeah
whenever I struggle with forgiving
I always
let me say it like whenever I struggle
with forgiving something
usually it's because I don't want to let
go of the power I hold over a situation
it's a way for me to Lord over to feel
better about myself
mm-hmm
and I just quite honestly have gotten to
a place in my life where I don't have
that energy anymore
and so I probably am too quick to
forgive because I'm not carrying any
more I'm not giving anybody else real
estate or rent free space in my head in
my body that is I don't have enough
space in there man it's a cloudy dark
messy place anyway right you're about to
say something
I think
I think you're right but I think I'm
also very frustrated uh his response to
finding this out somehow he had two
different accounts one in his dad's name
that he used in one in his name and I'm
not sure how that can happen but it did
and the one in his name stopped coming
out of his bank when they did the pause
in March of 2020 when we were engaged or
not yet engaged and uh then since it
just stopped coming out of the account
and we got married and he switched banks
and he just completely forgot about it
so I guess I'm disappointed that he
could be that irresponsible and then
disappointed that he hasn't shown a lot
of ambition since we found out last week
early last week about this because
you know I've been trying to straighten
out things with his credit and it's a
nightmare of getting this person on the
phone and that person on the phone away
and on hold and if he doesn't get
someone in five minutes he just wants to
hang up and okay listen listen listen I
feel like why is this my problem to
clean up there you go because you're not
yes doing it yes and you know what
you've become in short order you've
become his mom
and I tell him I don't want it to be
like that I know but you tell them you
don't want to neither and I know that
you tell him you don't want it to be
like that and then you go act like it
mm-hmm
quit being his mom
and here's the conversation
when you won't clean up this mess
I'm registering that is you don't care
about our financial safety
you don't care enough about me
well that's a childish response
that's immature
foreign
ever and I just suck at everything and I
no I'm not gonna have that
solve the problem
the problem is we found 14 000 more
dollars he's probably really ashamed and
embarrassed
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you can't be his mom Katie
you get to be disappointed you should be
you know what else I think you are
terrified
that you married a guy who thinks so
little of you
that he won't go get the counseling that
he needs
that he won't do the work that he needs
to stand up and stop feeding his shame
with secrets and negative self-talk and
inactivity and inaction
that you've married somebody who's so
undisciplined and unwilling to learn new
things
I think your body's terrified of the
next 65 years is what I think
am I right or wrong I do sometimes feel
like I can't trust him to lead our
family and man that he wants to be and
that I want him to be yes have you said
that to him
yes okay
your next step my sister is
to go see somebody
your marriage is in more trouble than
you think it is
because here's what happens next
shame as the great brene Brown says
shame eats secrets for breakfast
the engagements between you two when you
say hey have you dealt with your mess
that you brought to this marriage that's
now our mess have you made that call
Will it call for five minutes and adjust
it and you say am I not worth five more
minutes of your time
and then he shuts down
and then that leads to a culture
of secrecy where he just doesn't tell
you stuff
and that leads to more video games and
more time online and more Netflix and
more pornography and more now we're down
the road am I on the right track
yeah and then not not pornography I'll
say that that you know of Katie that you
know of it's like 90 something percent
of men and then you
have to create another world where you
can exist where bills actually get paid
in the real world where people have
difficult conversations with other
people
and that is the breeding ground for
resentment
when you wake up and you think I'm gonna
do this just because it's going to annoy
him
or he wakes up and says she's already
created her own world what does she even
care I'm just gonna do this because she
didn't even care about me
and that's resentment
and y'all are heading there faster than
you know
and so the beautiful thing is you're
brilliant I can tell
foreign
and I think he can get there with some
coaching
and with some compassion and some love
he also was probably gonna need a kick
in the booty here too okay
um not literally don't actually kick him
but do what he
need a marriage counselor ASAP
okay okay he will probably end up in his
Zone he's probably got some stuff from
home
if I'm a betting man
I would probably bet the dad may have
used some of that money he may have
taken out a loan of his own in some
shape form or fashion
it's very very common that that happens
or some sort of Parent PLUS Loan
situation where Mom and Dad take out a
loan that is supposed to go to tuition
who knows what who knows
all that said
carrying around the anger about the past
decisions that they made is a waste of
your energy
what you need to be invested in is
saying okay these things happened and
these character traits have emerged you
Katie are becoming somebody you don't
want to be you don't want to be your
husband's Mom right nobody wants to have
sex with their son that's gross it's
weird right and nobody wants to make out
with their mother right I don't want
this in my home
you are also becoming distrustful which
means you're going to start keeping
things to yourself or just doing things
on your own or talking to people at work
maybe even that guy who's hilarious and
he thinks you're pretty
you are becoming somebody you don't want
to be and you are seeing traits in him
that you don't want to be attached to
yet you said for better or worse so here
we are
and so we're going to go to marriage
counselor and we're going to learn new
ways of interacting with one another and
with ourselves and we're going to do
this a year and a half in you could end
up way decades ahead of most of the
couples in your life if y'all go do the
hard work right now
okay
okay he's gonna have to learn to not
shut down every time somebody calls us
calls us on him on the carpet he's going
to have to learn to do hard things
you're going to have to learn to hold
your boundaries and not be responsible
for how everybody else feels because
you've been a peacemaker most of your
life
okay
okay think of these not as Character
defects think of these as new skills
that you all have to learn because
neither of y'all have ever been married
before right
so we're learning new things moving
forward
what I will tell you as you're learning
new things and you're taking off running
in a New Direction carry as few bricks
with you as possible
set down the old crap man
your parents weren't perfect his weren't
either guaranteed
often they were less than perfect cool
I'm gonna own it they were I'm not
carrying their stuff anymore I got
enough of my own to carry
and the lighter the load is when y'all
take off into the woods carving a brand
new path together
um the easier that trip will be and by
the way the Trip's not easy
and let me answer go ahead and answer
this because this is going to come up on
the YouTube comments Katie if he says
I'm not going to marriage counseling
with you I refuse to go I don't need to
go
you can't make him
I'll be heartbroken for both of you but
you can't make him at that point you've
got to decide I'm gonna go on my own
because you need to learn some new
things because you don't like who you're
becoming
never forget this one important thing
you get to choose
you get to choose
you get to choose we'll be right back
all right we're back
let's go to Tyrus and Goldsboro North
Carolina what's up Tyrus
hey John how you doing I'm good what's
up man
uh definitely emphasize with her as well
as what she's going through with her
husband because I was that guy and then
that guy that's what we're calling about
we're on the other side of it oh awesome
to get out of it the whole time I was
talking to her I kept thinking man I
want to talk to her husband and then you
called so way to go yep yep yep so
what's up let's do this okay so actually
I was referred to you thankfully I've
listened to your podcast and thoroughly
enjoy it but I had called to Dave about
a financial question and I don't have a
financial problem according to everybody
I've got a lot of other stuff going on
all right let's unpack it
I'm angry naturally
uh very angry person
um at what trying to
stuff in the past that I want to be able
to get over what since it's having kids
what name it foreign
directed towards my mother and father
what what
I know I don't want to like you know
Gaslight anybody that's why I'm I'm
trying to be careful so I don't want to
be who my father was which was a very
angry person at whatever he was angry at
he took it out on us okay
and I met my wife God bless her
um a little over two years ago she had
four children from her previous marriage
and we had an eight month old of our own
so a lot of children love them a lot of
children
hey hold on that's a million kids
angry guy you're gonna meet I just think
anger's like a waste of most of my
energy yeah five kids would make me
probably just an angry guy from eight
months to 15 so quite a and I'm 25 so
I'm still a child myself at that a lot
of times you're 25.
yes
this is all I mean this is top five my
favorite calls ever already keep going
this is just good okay all right all
right boost my ego a little bit please
break me down
um so
I've heard a lot you talk a lot about
secrets and how they kill you yep
and it kind of not kind of it frustrates
me because I was known in my family and
like braggingly braggadociously the
steel trap of the family if you have a
secret come to Tyrus nobody will ever
find out
and it's it's listening to you say it
kills kills you like I forced myself to
basically become a robot because
I didn't have I'd never made enough time
to really look at myself and care about
myself it was always
bringing on other people's stuff
and what are you carrying that you don't
want to carry anymore
uh everybody's Secrets my own secrets
that I'm not even like what I just What
secrets
something was done to me at a very young
age that was not okay and he's sexually
abused yes okay listen I'm gonna be
super clear okay
your anger that cloud that swirl
lives and breathes ambiguous language
it lives and breathes these things and
these feelings and these other things
and these other things
one of the straightest paths through all
of this BS is naming stuff
that guy sexually abused me
that woman cheated on me you see what
I'm saying yeah it just shines a light
on all of it clears that fog out and now
we have something we can actually direct
ourselves at we don't do our bodies
don't let us do that because it's scared
rightfully so well it's it's messed up
because I'm not even scared for
people finding out what happened to me I
just don't want anybody getting in
trouble because it was years ago like it
sounds messed up I know but it's like
what good comes out from anybody knowing
what happened uh Hey listen
freedom
sleeping all night
I don't sleep I know you don't because
your body's still on 24 7 365 alert
watch
that's exactly right you know why
because your body remembers hate we
remember what it's like to be that age
remember what happens
stay extra vigilant
and then your brain takes up every bit
of emotional margin you have
so that eight-month-old does
eight-month-old stuff like spit up and
you lose your damn mind is that right
so much that she's actually perfect in
my eyes you know what I mean no no no
they spill juice and I'm like shut up
exactly exactly yes so here's what I'm
telling you what's going to come out of
it peace
your body put a GPS pin in that pain
and it has continued to beep on that pin
until you deal with it
until you let your body know
I'm a 25 year old father of five now I'm
in the driver's seat
you don't have to protect me anymore
because I'm not seven anymore I'm not 12
anymore
I'm not the family baggage keeper
anymore
all anger does man is it points us our
it's our bodies just pointing us towards
something we care about
and my guess is you really care deeply
about uh kids being safe
100 and you really care deeply about
people feeling loved
the challenge is you don't have the
tools on how to keep kids safe because
you're too busy keeping yourself safe
very fair it's not a moral judgment
that's a physiological judgment
you want to show people deep love and
you've never even seen that happen
because your parents are too busy saying
hey carry this for me carry this for me
carry this for me
and they used you like a pack mule
foreign
you should have been a little boy having
a good time
it doesn't matter it absolutely doesn't
matter
it's how is my body responding in the
present one of the things we know about
memory is that it's it's pretty faulty
it's pretty faulty
um what's important and this is from
Peter Dr Peter Levine's work this is
from vandercook's work what's really
important is less about the specifics
the minute details of something that
happened in our past
it's one of those memories do to our
bodies in the present
okay
[Music]
so here's a good example let's say when
I first got married my wife got in my
face and screamed and yelled
that's that's how what I remember 20
years later she planted her finger in my
face and screamed it yelled and told me
that I sucked at something right
let's say that we go through counseling
for years and by the way if you know my
wife she's I would never she would never
do that she would just stab me in my
sleep she would never yell at my face
um so let's say that 20 years later our
marriage is really good
and we've been through therapy together
we have two kids or three kids together
we have reconciled and we have one of
the best marriages ever
and then I do something I forget to pick
up my shoes and she looks up and just
that anger flashes
and my body instantly goes back to that
moment she was pointing in my face
now I could say remember that you've
been doing this our whole marriage
you're screaming and yelling at me and
she would say dude I didn't I never even
did that
I got mad once I never screamed and
yelled at whatever happened doesn't
matter what happens is my body's
responding right now am I safe yeah I'm
safe
I'm safe now
and I'm gonna take a big deep breath I'm
gonna hold it for a count of four or six
I'm gonna exhale it I'm gonna say these
words inside my mind or out loud
my body's trying to take care of me and
keep me safe I'm good
I'm gonna practice that see what I'm
saying
yeah I've actually because I'm horrible
about going on tangents hey quit talking
crap hey you're my friend quit talking
crap about yourself you talk about
yourself so bad
yeah it's self-talk's horrible it is
yeah I'm trying literally my number one
question I've got written here how to
rewire your brain to be
because it's I'd love to be in better
shape I'd love to not be angry I love
but in those moments the what I've done
before is just suppressed everything and
been a doormat like yeah okay like you
said you're too quick to forgive because
I didn't want to deal with it I was just
like yeah whatever I don't care steal
from me whatever you weren't you weren't
forgiving
you just open the door
yeah
forgiveness says I walk out on my front
porch and say
y'all stolen from me in the past you'll
have taken the most precious thing for
me which was my innocence you all did
that I'm not carrying that crap for
y'all anymore I'm setting it down
and you are not welcome in my home and
you walk inside your house and you lock
the door
what you've done is you walk down the
front porch and said hey
I'm just not going to think about y'all
anymore the front door in the back door
wide open
yeah right and you let them ransack the
place and that's not forgiveness that's
avoidance
yeah
okay
so here's the uh
here's where we start
and let me paint you a broader picture
we live in a culture that would tell you
just set some goals
instead of weight loss goal and crush it
and kill it and set a financial goal and
dominate that good right
um
whenever you feel angry just flex and
stop being angry like that's that's how
we approach it and that's in there it's
stupid it's a waste of energy and a
waste of time you burn out that's right
your willpower is much less powerful
than your systems
okay
we're going to start with identity
so what I want you to do today is to go
to like Michael's or or Home Depot or
someplace and either get like a really
nice piece of plywood or get a nice
um piece of cardstock or something
and somewhere in your home I want you to
hang it up and I want you to write on it
with a with a permanent marker and is
nice lettering as you can do
I am a man who
honors and loves my family
I am a man who
is in control of his emotions
I am a man who is a good Steward of my
body
I am a man who will
own what my parents did
and never repeat it again
what we're going to do is we're going to
set identity statements this is who I am
and then we're going to go backfill
those identities with some actions
they're going to make those things
possible with some systems they're going
to make that possible okay
right and let me just preface this
because it was not my parents I know
that they I I I I just want to get that
out there in case anybody hears my
parents listen listen I just wanted
everybody hold on
you still think you are responsible for
the adults in your life
you are not
I don't care who it was
you're not responsible for how your
parents feel not one time did you tell
me that it was them
and you're just I know I know I just
heard you say what they did I didn't
want you to think no I I get that
but I also want you to know you are not
responsible for the emotional regulation
of the adults in your life that's their
job okay and if if your parents listen
to this and they go bananas we never do
you have to say I never said you did
they will possibly if they don't know be
devastated
that their kid was hurt like that and
they didn't know or they did know about
it and they didn't know how to respond
and so they pretended it never happened
so that's where that's why I'm so angry
hey
and you damn well should be
because if they didn't know that's
exactly worth it have you ever asked
them
I don't that's why I asked about how do
you know
I was six at the time okay seven so it's
weird that I remember stuff from four
years old and I don't it's like it
happened and then black
so I don't know if they know I don't
know if they don't know but so listen if
they did know to be fair I don't have a
relationship with them okay so it may be
as I was about to be my next question
what's your relationship like with him
if you don't talk to them if they're out
of your life then a conversation with
them is of no value
yeah okay
um that's you just running up and
lobbing grenades at them if they're out
of your life okay
if you have to reconcile the fact that
you were sexually abused and your
parents may have known about it and they
chose nothing
that I I can't think of something more
Justified to be angry about
and it's ruined all of my relationships
no it hasn't no it happens you have I
have correct okay I can't it's been hard
so hard to trust people and not be yes
I've just only become vulnerable with my
wife recently good good hey and I I
would like hear me honor that man
it's so good you are 15 years ahead of
me dude before I learned that kind of
vulnerability you are way ahead of the
game
yeah okay I'm proud of you that's hard
man it's real real hard saying things
out loud
um
but I don't want you to start blaming
the anger for things because you've got
choices
sure okay absolutely and moving forward
I want us to practice man
you are trying to engage in something
that you've never seen done you've had
somebody describe the game of baseball
to you
and then somebody handed you a bat and
said go play and you're like okay some
guy on a hill is gonna throw a ball at
me and I gotta hit it with a stick okay
and then I gotta run where where am I
running right right see what I'm saying
you are figuring out what true honest
vulnerable connected accountable
parenting looks like in real time and
you've never seen it actually done
give yourself some Grace okay
okay
it's gonna be hard oh by the way you're
dealing with four people who've got a
different dad
all right
that's hard too
yeah you know what we should put on top
of that you know we should dump on top
of that an infant that sounds cool
and a dog that sits in the house all the
time why not let's have a dog
let's see if we can come up with any
other thing to ruin our sex life and our
Intimacy in our financial life like
right you know what I'm saying you're in
it dude and you are in it in your
eyeballs
yeah
I heard the great Terry reel one of the
most incredible therapists ever I think
foreign
he said that he recommends people who
are struggling with anger
to carry around a picture of their mom
and dad
and put in their wallet
and every time or put on your phone and
every time you're about to unleash on
one of your kids or on your wife
pull out your phone look at that picture
no no I'm kidding pull out that phone
and look at him and say hey Mom and Dad
this one's for you
foreign
I'm here to honor you
and he reports that
people stop their angry outbursts
immediately and they never pick him up
again
yeah what we're looking for is a gap
between stimulus and response okay
that impulse to yell and the actual
yelling yourself the actual yelling
itself
if you can
put Even a Splinter of a wedge in
between those two things you got a shot
okay
okay I can't recommend enough
can't recommend enough that you need to
call somebody and go talk to somebody
okay
because not only do you have the abuse
in the background the potential parental
involvement and all that mess
but you probably have a wake of people
behind you that you've hurt over the
years out of your own pain is that fair
and that's putting it lightly and that
pain creates great guilt which turns
into great shame which then eats those
secrets and you see how this thing turns
into a loop
yep and then here's this is the
important part
if you don't deal with this
you are making a conscious choice to
hand this off to those five kids
and that's why I'm calling like I don't
I don't want to be
the father that they're scared to say
there you go hey Dad I got drunk can you
come pick me up or if I messed up can
you help me I didn't have that that's
right and what that's going to look like
ultimately is
um I want to be I want I don't want to
be that dead either
so this morning I got up
before I usually get up to get my
workout in
so that then I could get my whatever
thinking or praying or writing time
whatever nonsense I do in the mornings
so that I could have breakfast with my
12 year old
every Tuesday morning
so that one day in four or five or six
years he's gonna find himself in a mess
and he's going to know not because I
said something
but because I showed up over and over
and over
I'm planting seeds and the fruit's not
going to be I'm not going to taste that
for years
see what I'm saying
yeah I don't mind if they do the 12 year
old hate I hate you and stomp upstairs
but when they're 30 I want them
to call me that's right that's right and
they're going to learn how to call you
by you calling them
and they're going to learn how to reach
out to you
by you
reaching out to them
and they're going to learn how to treat
women by how you treat their mother
and they're going to learn how to tip
and honor the waitress even when the
food sucks because of how you do it
and they're going to learn how to say
ham really spun up right now I'm gonna
take a walk around the house give me 30
minutes and then we'll have this
conversation
okay
yeah hear me say this you get to change
everything
and I'm sick to my stomach that somebody
hurt you when you were young
if you hear nothing else brother hear me
say that shouldn't happen and I'm sorry
and I'm sorry that there was no adults
there to protect you and I'm sorry there
was no adults there to comfort you
you deserved better than that
I appreciate that okay
and now everything moving forward is a
choice
I'm gonna give you a copy of own your
past change your future okay my latest
book it's going to walk you through it
I'm gonna send it to you for free I'm
also gonna send you four or five decks
of the questions for humans here's what
those are
I actually talked to my wife about that
like 10 minutes before I got on the call
you know what they are but let me tell
you what they really are
they are tools for dads to talk to their
kids
to teach fathers how to have
conversations with the children well
that's the best thing you've said or
given to me not not to downplay anything
else but thank you that's what I need
cool
because you're not gonna have to stand
there awkwardly at your kids you're
gonna be able to take that 15 year old
out and you're gonna have these cards
you'll be like all right we're gonna I'm
gonna ask you these questions you ask me
and I'm you're gonna answer them
honestly
and my son asked me this morning when we
were going through uh math flash cards
he asked me
hey Dad did you how did you do math
you know what I told him
when I was a middle school son I cheated
like crazy in math
I'm ashamed of it
and I robbed myself of learning how to
do math which made high school math
almost impossible which made Collegiate
and doctoral statistics a nightmare
I'm glad that you have chosen to be a
person of integrity
something
and I got to honor my son by telling him
the truth about who his dad used to be
and now he knows his dad is a fanatic
about cheating and telling the truth I'm
obsessive about it because I used to be
a lying little thief
you see what I'm saying but those cars
give you an opportunity to have that
conversation without it being weird
right right will you use him if I send
them
absolutely that's awesome awesome so
today here's your homework I'm gonna
send you some stuff for free your
homework is
to go get a board of some sort that's
going to be your identity and tension
it's going to be home based for you
here's who I'm going to become
and then you and your wife man y'all
spend some time backfilling that how do
I get there how do I get to be a guy
that stewards his body I need 35 minutes
in the morning in the garage I'm gonna
go buy two kettlebells at Academy and
I'm gonna just pick up or two dumbbells
I'm gonna pick up a workout online
I'm just gonna go for walks for 30
minutes in the morning I'm gonna start
there and maybe two years from now I'll
have a big membership at a CrossFit gym
or I'm a start there how do I become a
guy who is less reactive and less angry
foreign
[Music]
I'm gonna stay off my phone
I'm going to leave this toxic job
I'm gonna ask you just to wink when you
feel me getting riled up
[Music]
I'm gonna go tell my kids hey I'm super
sorry I shouldn't have talked to you
like that and on and on and on
you know Tyrus I I know one thing
can do this
and go call counselor brother you
deserve the healing we'll be right back
hey what's up now that my new book oh in
your past change your futures out in the
wild we've been hearing reviews and
feedback from readers and wow I'm so
grateful and one of the things I've been
most excited about hearing is that this
book is not just for people who are
healing from terrible traumatic
experience or other big scary things
from their past this book is for
everyone in every Walk of Life the
single 30 year old looking to sharpen
their mind the 25 year old hoping to
make new friends the parent who's tired
of seeing their kids eyes glued to a
screen but who doesn't know how to
re-enter their life people coming out of
abusive relationships everyone and this
book isn't me talking at you this book
is me walking with you because I've been
there too to better understand and
improve your mental relational and
emotional health please check out own
your past change your future at John
deloney.com today that's John
deloney.com today
all right we're back and as we wrap up
two days show man Today's Show got it
was heavier than I anticipated BM
man shout out to the folks who called we
got some Brave callers on the line today
um and uh band Talking Heads the song's
called Burning Down the House
I almost made a fart joke but I'm not
gonna do that lyrics go like this watch
out you might get what you're after cool
baby strange but not a stranger I'm an
ordinary guy Burning Down the House
hold tight wait till the party's over
hold tight we're in for nasty weather
there's got to be a way
Burning Down The House here's your
ticket pack your bags time for jumping
overboard the transportation is here
close enough but not too far maybe you
know where you are fighting fire with
fire we'll see you soon
[Music]